I quoted to you at length from
the Tudor Homily on Obedience
first published in 1547 with
its stress on hierarchy,
degree, order,
subordination,
and obedience.
And yet as you know within two
years of the publication of that
homily in 1547 there was a wave
of peasant protest in 1549 right
across the south of England and
open rebellion in East Anglia,
Kett's Rebellion.
This was a society in which the
common people below the level of
the 'middling sort',
the leaders of village society,
had no formal political voice.
They were, as Sir Thomas Smith
put it,
"to be ruled over and not
to rule others,"
and yet not infrequently we
find those same common people
raising their voices in protest
and sometimes in demand.
It was a society in which the
gentry rulers regarded their
social inferiors with a great
deal of condescension.
The language they used to
describe them says it all:
the "meaner sort of
people,"
"the clowns,"
"the ruder sort,"
"the rabble."
And they expected their
deference.
Men were expected to uncover
their heads before their social
superiors,
do them "hat honor,"
as it was called,
women were expected to bob a
curtsy,
and yet this condescension on
the part of the gentry was
tinged with anxiety and an
expectation of insubordination.
As one of them,
Sir John Oglander,
put it, "the common people
are always apt to rebel and
mutiny upon the least
occasion."
Well, how can one reconcile all
of these paradoxes?
Well, maybe the answer is in
fact simple enough.
Deference and obedience was the
norm,
it was instilled by precept,
it was learned by repeated
daily experience,
and yet periodically it could
perhaps be destabilized by
circumstances;
a famine perhaps,
a particularly callous example
of exploitation by a landlord.
Things like that could perhaps
render people desperate,
leading them to rise in a
convulsive spasm of anger and
despair,
and when that happened all good
order could be threatened by the
mob,
what the gentry called the
"many-headed monster,"
the common people,
"the beast with many
heads."
Well, it's a powerful image and
not without historical
foundation,
and yet to characterize all or
even most forms of popular
disturbance in early modern
England in this way is
profoundly misleading.
A generation of research on
popular protest has shown just
how inadequate that stereotype
is,
and the resulting shift of
perception amongst historians is
reflected in the kind of
language they now use to
describe these things.
People nowadays talk little
about 'the mob';
they talk more about 'the
crowd'.
They talk less about 'revolt'
and more about 'protest and
resistance'.
We've moved from the study of
'riots' to the study of what
people term 'popular political
culture'.
Now whether that term is fully
justified we'll see,
but the evidence at least
reveals that the common people
were neither unconditionally
deferential to their rulers nor
on the other hand were they
secretly alienated from the
existing social order,
but rather, as one laboring man
from Northamptonshire in the
English Midlands put it on one
of these occasions,
they could--to quote him,
they could "tell well
enough how to devise a means to
help themselves."
And they could do that within
the parameters of the prevailing
structures of power and
authority within which they were
obliged to work because as yet
no one had suggested any
possible alternative.
Popular protest has been well
described by John Walter as
being in the first instance a
"politics of
subsistence,"
a politics of subsistence.
Its most immediate objectives
were frequently the defense or
the amelioration of a
threatening economic situation.
The most obvious case of that
was in the case of food riots.
These tended to occur in years
of dearth;
bad harvest years when grain
was in short supply and the
prices of food rocketed,
years like 1587,1594 to '7,1622
to '3,
1631,1647 to '8, and so on.
These riots also occurred in
years of industrial depression
when rural industrial workers in
particular who were dependent
upon the market for most of
their food supplies found that
they lacked the income to supply
themselves because their
employers were no longer able to
put out work to them.
The 1620s saw some very bad
industrial depressions of that
kind.
Well, either circumstance,
a bad harvest or a year of
industrial slump,
could produce a sudden and
catastrophic decline in what
economists refer to as people's
'exchange entitlements' as
consumers,
or in plain English,
they were unable to afford the
food that they needed.
Agrarian disturbances were
rather less predictable,
but they occurred sporadically
and occasionally in areas,
or individual communities,
where the manorial tenants,
or the local population more
generally,
were confronted with changes
which threatened to undermine
the viability of particular
patterns of local rural economy.
So, in 1536,
as you know,
part of the causes of the
Pilgrimage of Grace rising were
protests against the pushing up
of entry fines for land in parts
of northwestern England.
In 1549, Kett's Rebellion was
rooted in protests against the
exploitation of landlords'
grazing rights.
But above all in the late
sixteenth and early seventeenth
centuries the grievance which
motivated protests was
enclosure;
enclosure of the land which
extinguished rights of common
pasture;
pasture rights which were
particularly valued.
So, for example,
in the small town of
Berkhamstead,
which is just to the north-west
of London in the county of
Hertfordshire,
in 1618, several villages
existed around a very large area
of common land on which they all
had rights to graze their cattle
and sheep;
they had rights to put their
pigs into the woodland;
they had rights to gather fuel
and wild fruits and to capture
small animals for the pot,
rabbits in particular.
The loss of all that,
when attempts were made to
enclose Berkhamstead common,
were deeply resented,
and that's the kind of
situation that so often
occurred.
Now situations of that kind
occurred sporadically though
sometimes they also came in
clusters.
In 1607, there was a wave of
enclosures in villages where the
three counties of
Northamptonshire,
Warwickshire,
and Leicestershire met in the
Midlands up here.
That was known as the 'Midland
Rising' because there was a kind
of scattering of riots across
the whole area.
Or again in 1628 to 1632 there
occurred what's known as the
'Western Rising' in the forested
areas of the west of England.
Those areas were being
disafforested and cleared and
the land turned into enclosed
farms,
and much resistance sprang up
amongst those who had formerly
enjoyed common rights in the
woodlands.
And finally in the--from the
1630s,
in response to the drainage of
the Fenlands of eastern England
and the allocation of reclaimed
land in enclosed farms to those
who invested in that
improvement,
there was a wave of resistance.
The people of the Fens to the
south of the Wash and in
Lincolnshire lost,
as a result of the drainage,
their grazing rights,
their fishing rights,
their wildfowling rights,
the rights to gather rushes and
turf for thatch or fuel,
and they bitterly resisted
these changes in the so-called
'Fenland Riots' which actually
sputtered on for over thirty
years.
Okay.
So we're dealing primarily with
forms of protest against,
or forms of resistance to,
circumstances which had a
detrimental effect upon the
household economies of the
inhabitants of particular
districts,
and those circumstances were
felt at one time or another all
over England and Wales.
But there was also rather more
to it than that,
although it took historians
quite a while to appreciate the
fact.
When people first started
looking closely at the records
which survive relating to these
events,
the most immediately striking
thing about the evidence was
that these risings,
revolts, or riots were in fact
relatively restrained and
relatively purposefully
directed.
Perhaps we'd been misled by the
very term "riot,"
which was often used to
describe them in the legal
records.
That word of course conjures up
an image of lurid breakdown of
order,
but in fact in English law a
riot was simply an unlawful act
committed by three or more
people who had assembled for the
purpose.
As a result,
the reality of those events
which are described
conventionally as 'riots' could
be much less harrowing than the
image which the term tends to
conjure up in our minds.
So, take food riots for example.
First of all,
they were by no means an
automatic response to the
existence of a dearth or
scarcity of food.
They were in fact relatively
few even in pretty bad years.
Their form was also relatively
restrained.
Crowds didn't simply seize food
from anyone who had a stock of
food to be seized;
the gentry or big farmers with
well-stocked barns,
for example.
In fact, food riots were almost
exclusively directed at
middlemen in the grain trade.
They were almost entirely
directed against corn dealers.
Again, crowds involved in these
riots rarely stole food and took
it away.
More likely they involved the
stopping of middlemen who were
transporting grain which they
had bought up in bulk in the
market and forcing them to sell
it to the crowd at prices below
the inflated market rate;
that's to say at prices which
local people thought they could
afford.
And finally they very rarely
involved violence against
people.
Quite often food riots
involved, or were even led by,
women who could be quite
violent in their language and
their threats but rarely
physically violent.
The object was to prevent the
removal of grain,
to keep it in the area,
and to force those who had it
to sell it to local people,
rather than to attack them
personally.
So essentially it appears to be
the case that these were
protests against dysfunctions in
the developing internal traffic
in foodstuffs.
Such a trade,
especially in grain,
was essential to supply
England's growing cities and
those areas of the countryside
which are often described as
'dependent areas' which didn't
produce enough grain for the
local population's needs.
But the system of internal
trade which was developing was
not yet sufficiently well
developed to iron out regional
inequalities in the supply of
foodstuffs which was available
in bad years,
and in addition that system
offered opportunities or
temptations to evade the law.
The law stated that the poor
should always be served first in
the market,
at prices which were agreed by
the market officers as
reasonable,
before large-scale commercial
dealers were allowed to
participate.
Yet that law was frequently
flouted.
In Hertfordshire for example to
the north of London,
in 1598 the local justices had
to deal with the major problem
of large-scale dealers who were
supplying the London food market
intercepting grain before it
ever came to the local markets,
buying it on the road and
removing it immediately to
London.
Problems of that kind could
provoke a great deal of local
resentment.
And this kind of situation
helps to explain the geography
of food riots.
They tended to take place in or
near market towns in heavily
populated areas with many
consumers dependent upon those
markets.
They took place in or around
market towns of food-exporting
areas where the local poor
witnessed commercial dealers
buying up supplies at prices
which they couldn't afford,
in order to ship the grain
elsewhere.
And they occurred in areas that
such dealers passed through on
their way to major urban
markets.
In particular,
one finds a lot of food rioting
in the market catchment area of
London,
in the southeast,
and in the southwest around the
great city of Bristol;
similarly to a lesser degree
around Norwich in East Anglia.
So these actions were aimed at
rectifying quite specific forms
of local grievance,
a sense amongst local
populations that they were being
exploited by middlemen in the
grain trade and abused.
Where there was no such
grievance the poor seemed simply
to have tightened their belts in
bad years or even in some parts
of the north and far west to
have starved quietly.
And those of them who did take
action usually did it in a
fairly purposeful manner,
focusing on achieving a
specific end--
supplying their own needs at
prices that they could afford.
Defending, one could say in the
jargon, their 'exchange
entitlements'.
Well, similarly,
agrarian disturbances present a
less lurid picture than the one
conjured up by the word
"riot."
They certainly often involved
large crowds of people who had
assembled together to prevent an
enclosure,
or to reverse it,
or to prevent the drainage of
Fenland,
or to reverse it, and so forth;
knocking down hedges and
fences, blocking drainage works
and so forth.
But they were also relatively
orderly.
Surprisingly often agrarian
riots were announced in advance.
They were even sometimes
preceded by meetings in the
local manor court or in the
church at which the tenants
would agree upon their action.
In one village for example
called Ryton,
R-y-t-o-n, up in the northeast
of England,
in 1607, the manor court
actually required all tenants to
turn up with a spade or an ax in
order to take down an enclosure
to which they objected.
They even laid it down in the
manor court, as a bylaw,
that any tenant who failed to
turn up to take part would be
fined six pence.
Sometimes these actions were
initiated having been agreed
upon by a public signal,
quite often the tolling of the
church bells.
They frequently involved the
gathering of whole communities:
men, women, and children
together.
Sometimes they were led by
local notables.
Sometimes the minister of the
parish might be the leader.
Sometimes they were led by
parish or manorial officers,
or members of the manorial
jury.
Sometimes they even enjoyed the
tacit support of sympathetic
local gentlemen,
who might themselves be losing
out from a particular enclosure
and were content to encourage
some action against it,
even though they rarely took
part themselves.
One of the reasons that Oliver
Cromwell was so popular in
eastern England,
in the Fenlands that he came
from, was the fact that in 1628
he had defended the rioters in
the Fens in Parliament against
the innovations that they were
protesting against.
He was known as the "Lord
of the Fens"
for his popularity in the area.
It didn't hurt when he later
recruited his regiments there.
Riots often involved a strong
element of ritual.
Frequently, they involved the
ritual removal of a fence or a
hedge.
Sometimes those who pulled down
fences or hedges did it two at a
time to avoid the legal
definition of a riot as an
illegal act committed by three
or more persons.
Sometimes the youth,
or the women of the community,
were to the fore in this action
in order to evade severe
punishment.
It was thought that they would
be held less culpable.
Sometimes hedges were pulled
down by men dressed as women,
and this transvestite element
in the ritual of rioting is
quite fascinating.
It perhaps symbolized a world
turned upside down.
No one could have deceived
themselves that these were
actually women.
They had beards for a start.
>
But they dressed as women
sometimes, perhaps symbolizing a
world turned upside down.
Fences and hedges once they
were destroyed were sometimes
sawn up and burned,
or even ritually buried.
Sometimes the land returned
into tillage was ritually plowed
to symbolize its return to the
manorial community,
or sometimes where it was
common pasture which was being
defended,
animals were put back onto it
by the villagers in order to
symbolize their reclamation of
their common pasture.
And quite often all of this
might be accompanied by a rather
festive atmosphere.
Cakes and ale were frequently
prepared to be enjoyed
afterwards, often around a
bonfire.
Music sometimes accompanied the
proceeding.
There might be dancing.
In the Fenlands they enjoyed a
game which was known as
"Fenland football."
This was the original form of
football in which large crowds
of young men simply chased
across the countryside kicking
an inflated pig's bladder.
In the Fenland when they got
together for Fenland football,
they kicked it across the
countryside and destroyed every
drainage ditch that they passed
in the course of chasing the
ball.
It's interesting also that
these actions often took place
upon festival days.
The rising in the Midlands in
1607 started on May Day.
Shrove Tuesday in February was
often a popular date.
It was a time known for village
games which involved rituals of
inversion, turning the world
upside down for a day.
Another popular occasion was
Rogation Day,
the day on which people
perambulated the boundaries of
the parish to note the parish
boundaries,
and that's something I'll
return to.
And again, agrarian risings of
this kind very rarely involved
violence against people.
The crowds might appear very
threatening.
There were rarely any injuries
to individuals.
Indeed, those against whom the
crowd were rioting or protesting
very often kept out of the way.
So what we're dealing with are
occasions which were often very
highly targeted and very
purposeful affairs,
rather than outbreaks of
anarchy and unrestrained
violence.
It's equally evident that they
were expressive of a kind of
moral order,
which involved not just defense
of the material interests of the
community,
important as that was,
but expressed also a set of
values: what E.P.
Thompson in a famous phrase
described as the "moral
economy of the crowd,"
by which he meant a popular
consensus about the nature of
legitimate and illegitimate
practices in economic life,
involving notions of the proper
behavior expected from different
sections of the community,
and asserting notions of
certain popular rights in the
economic sphere.
Rioters do indeed very often
seem to have been infused with a
strong sense of the rectitude of
their acts.
They were sustained in that by
certain legitimizing ideas.
As one might expect,
in agrarian disturbances the
vital legitimizing idea was that
of custom.
As you know,
in any individual manor,
custom constituted a kind of
local lived-in environment of
norms and usages,
a collection of rights which
people believed to have existed
"time out of mind to which
the memory of no man is to the
contrary,"
in the phrase they often used;
"time out of mind."
And to that extent custom
provided a powerful legitimating
rhetoric for actions of this
kind.
For example,
in 1630 when the tenants of one
manor in the southwest of
England defended their claim to
pasture rights in the forests
they were able to produce ten
witnesses whose average age was
seventy-eight,
quite extraordinarily old
people for this period,
who testified to the existence
of their customs in the
woodlands during their own long
lives and in those of their
fathers and of their
grandfathers,
as they had been told when they
were children.
But in the changing
circumstances of the sixteenth
and early seventeenth centuries
custom had become not only a set
of long-established rights and
practices but also,
in a time of change,
a potential arena of conflict
between landlords and tenants.
If the tenants were trying to
defend what they took to be the
antiquity and reasonableness of
customs which protected their
interests,
many landlords were anxious to
explode those claims,
or to persuade people,
or to pressurize people,
into removing customs which
inhibited what they saw as
'improvement' of their estates.
With that kind of conflict of
interests,
when push came to shove the
notion of the sanctity and
wisdom of custom strengthened
the arm of those who tried to
resist claims against local
customs which were detrimental
to their interests.
In the case of enclosure,
they saw themselves also as
resisting a kind of innovation
which had been declared illegal
by various statutes throughout
the sixteenth century.
The laws against enclosure in
fact were repealed in 1624,
but the fact that enclosure had
for long been declared illegal
by Parliament was remembered,
and that again gave a sense of
legitimacy.
And some rioters could even
claim a higher authority.
As I mentioned,
very often enclosure riots took
place on Rogation Day.
That was the day when
traditionally the older members
of the village community
gathered together with some of
the youngest members,
in particular young boys,
to walk the boundaries of the
parish,
to 'beat the bounds' as it was
called.
The Church of England even had
a special homily for Rogation
Day and it had some significant
texts.
One of them was Deuteronomy
27:17: "cursed be he that
removes his neighbor's
landmark."
Another was Proverbs 22:28:
"remove not the ancient
landmark which thy fathers have
set."
The rituals of walking the
boundaries of the parish were
all about such landmarks,
they were all about such
boundaries,
such common territories and
their sanctity,
and they tried to impress upon
the young boys who were part of
the procession,
where exactly the boundaries
were.
There were various rituals
involved in this.
If a boundary involved a
stream, then one of the boys
might be thrown in the stream to
help him remember where it was.
>
It was common if there were
boundary stones to get one of
the boys to touch the stone with
his finger after which the
finger was twisted by one of the
older men to give him a sharp
pain to remind him.
One village practiced sitting
little boys on the stones with
their bare bottoms.
They sometimes even struck a
child at particular boundary
spots so that they would
remember the place.
It was all part of the ritual.
If such occasions sometimes
ended with purposeful attacks
upon new-fangled boundaries
which had been erected in the
form of enclosure and which
excluded local inhabitants from
formerly common land,
then they may very well have
had a sense of divine approval
for what they did in defending
their boundaries.
As for food rioters,
they had a strong enough sense
of their own right to have food
available at reasonable prices.
When she was asked what had
motivated her to take part in
the stopping of a grain shipment
in 1629,
one woman from Essex said it
was, to quote her,
"the cry of the country
and my own want";
and my own want."
Grain rioters could also claim,
with some justification,
to be merely enforcing the law.
They could see themselves as
engaging in a kind of mass
citizen's arrest of grain
dealers who were breaching
market regulations,
or they could see themselves as
enforcing the regulations
supposed to be put into effect
in times of scarcity which the
local magistrates should have
enforced.
And frequently grain riots
broke out where the magistrates
had been slow to do so.
So then, rioting crowds had an
empowering sense of the
rectitude of their actions.
But of course they weren't
simply disinterested upholders
of custom and law.
They were also defending their
own interests,
and in that endeavor riot was a
tactic in a kind of negotiation
with local authorities.
Very often food riots were
preceded by petitioning;
petitioning the local
magistrates to act to relieve
distress and to put into
operation scarcity regulations.
It was commonly the case,
as I've already observed,
that such riots came after
weeks of deteriorating
circumstances during which the
local magistrates had been slow
to act.
Hence, you could see riots as
being in some sense a kind of
"petitioning in strength
and in deed."
Agrarian riots were often in a
similar way a particular stage
in a process of dispute and
negotiation.
That might include,
for example,
initial appeals to people who
had set in motion enclosure
schemes to desist and give them
up.
The appeal might come from a
local minister.
It might come from sympathetic
local gentlemen.
It might come from the women of
the parish.
It might come from the manorial
jury.
If that failed,
then there were a number of
informal sanctions which could
be taken to try to put moral
pressure upon those who were
engaged in an enclosure.
So for example,
in 1616 in a village called
Over Compton,
which is in Dorset down in the
southwest,
a local enclosing landlord who
was called Andrew Abington found
a paper stuck on the church door
when he came to church one
Sunday.
The paper read,
"Here be Andrew Abington's
Commandments,"
and it followed:
"Thou shalt do no right.
Thou shalt catch what thou
canst.
Thou shalt pay no man.
Thou shalt bear false witness
against thy neighbors.
Thou shalt deny thine own
hand," that is deny
responsibility.
And shortly afterwards,
Andrew Abington's Commandments,
having embarrassed him at the
church door,
had been set to music and were
being sung around the local ale
houses as an effort to humiliate
him.
Or again there could be
anonymous threats.
One landlord in Warwickshire in
1607 received an anonymous
letter threatening that action
would be taken if he proceeded
with the enclosure,
and the letter was signed
"Thomas Unhedgeall";
Thomas Unhedgeall.
Another form of action
frequently taken was to initiate
lawsuits.
Sometimes tenants would get
together and pool their
resources in a common fund to
bring a case.
At Neroche Forest in Somerset
in the west country,
for example,
tenants anxious to defend the
woodlands "put their purses
together,"
as it was put,
on the advice of the
sympathetic steward of another
local gentleman,
who gave them that advice after
an open meeting,
and then with their common
purse they hired a lawyer to
bring a case to try to prevent
the enclosure.
When a riot came it was often
also a deliberate tactic to get
the case heard in an
authoritative central court,
especially the Court of Star
Chamber meeting in Westminster.
The Court of Star Chamber,
as one of the highest courts in
the land,
was staffed with councillors
who were often reasonably
sympathetic to the interests of
the local tenantry and who might
further their case or force
arbitration in the interests of
preserving public order.
A riot, which could provoke a
landlord to bring a case in Star
Chamber,
was an excellent way of having
local grievances heard before an
authoritative forum and had the
additional advantage of getting
it done at the expense of the
landlord who brought the case.
So there's a tactical element
in many enclosure riots and
that's, of course,
an important reason for their
relative restraint.
They were a way of calling the
authorities' attention to
grievances;
a way of putting pressure on
the authorities to act and to
remedy these discontents.
And surprisingly often it
worked.
Magistrates did put emergency
dearth regulations into
operation in the aftermath of
food riots.
Punishments of food riots were
usually relatively few and
relatively light.
Or again Star Chamber or other
central courts quite frequently
ordered the settlement of
particular disputes by a process
of arbitration and sometimes
indeed they even found for the
tenants and forbade the planned
enclosure.
But, if action on the part of
local people was not restrained
in that way it could be a very
different story.
At Maldon on the coast of Essex
in 1629 for example,
there were two food riots.
The first of them ended in the
authorities taking action to put
scarcity regulations into effect
and punishing very few people
and punishing them only lightly.
When a second riot took place,
the authorities lost their
patience.
A special commission was sent
down from Westminster which
tried those involved as
ringleaders in the riots and
hanged four of them,
including the leader of the
Maldon riots,
Ann Carter, who was known to
her followers as 'Captain Ann'.
Or again in the Midlands in
1607 the spread of rioting
against enclosure from parish to
parish was eventually deemed by
the authorities to be so
threatening that they defined it
as treasonable rebellion.
Martial law was declared and
the rising was put down with
another crop of executions,
including the execution of the
leader,
John Reynolds,
known to his followers as
'Captain Pouch'.
He got that name because he had
a leather pouch in which he
claimed to have authority from
the king to oppose enclosures.
When he was taken,
it was found that his pouch
contained his lunch,
some bread and cheese.
Interestingly,
in the new Oxford Dictionary
of National Biography you'll
find both Ann Carter and Captain
Pouch included amongst the
dignitaries of national history.
The--our sense of the past has
broadened wide enough to include
people who previously would have
had no place.
Well, that kind of outcome,
if things were deemed to have
gone too far,
could very sharply remind the
common people only too
graphically of who ruled in
sixteenth- and
seventeenth-century England.
And that kind of flat
repression of discontent was
usually a sign that the
authorities had become nervous.
And it raises a further point.
The usual focus in the
literature upon the relative
order and the rationality and
the tactical good sense of
popular protest,
and on the usual moderation of
response on the part of the
authorities,
all of this is true.
And yet it runs the risk of
making it all seem a little bit
too neat, a little bit too
orderly.
I think we have to remember
also that there was a good deal
of danger in all of this
activity;
sometimes quite serious danger.
One mustn't forget that the
participants in many of these
actions were very anxious and
sometimes very angry.
We mustn't forget that
sometimes what began as a
specific, localized,
limited, protest could
escalate.
The outstanding example is
Kett's Rebellion in 1549,
which began as an enclosure
riot and ended of course with
open rebellion and indeed a
pitched battle.
That was very exceptional.
Nonetheless,
that possibility did exist.
The point is that as a tactic
of protest and as a tactic of
negotiation with rulers,
riot could be a rather
dangerous game of brinkmanship.
The authorities for their part
had to try to contain it.
They were expected to respond.
They had to retain their
authority and their credibility
by responding in the right kind
of way.
The crowd for its part often
pushed and menaced,
but it had to avoid going too
far if it was not to provoke
pretty severe retaliation.
Acts of insubordination had to
be tricked out with the
appearance of ultimate deference
to authority.
The responses of concession and
conciliation which the
authorities made had to retain
the appearance of gracious
magnanimity on the part of
rulers,
concerned rulers.
That was the best way to save
their face.
It seems to be the case that
for the most part this delicate
line was held,
which is, in a way,
a tribute on the one hand to
the skill with which the
leadership of the crowds
conducted their actions and,
on the other hand,
the skill with which many of
the magistrates tried to defuse
what were potentially very
explosive situations.
But of course that doesn't
necessarily mean that the
protestors were sincere in the
postures of deference which they
might adopt in the face of
authority when they negotiated
with them,
and it certainly doesn't mean
that popular protest was,
as some historians have argued,
essentially un-political.
When people describe these
actions as un-political what
they seem to mean is that they
involved no challenge to the
authority of the state,
and that they were not
indicative of any revolutionary
attempt to overthrow the
established social order.
Well, of course they didn't!
Even the most determined of
protestors had no alternative
model of the social and
political order to appeal to.
There are no conceptions of
equal rights.
democracy.
They had to work within the
structures of power and
authority in a hierarchical
society as they found them.
Their objectives were
necessarily limited.
But that doesn't mean that
their objectives were not
'political' in the sense that
they were attempting to exert
some influence on how power was
exercised,
influence on how power was
exercised within their local
communities.
These forms of popular protest
one could say,
in that sense,
were quintessentially political
in the sense that they advanced
claims by local people to be
considered;
that they advanced claims to
certain rights--
to eat, to enjoy the
common--rights which they were
very aware of even in a social
system that permitted them no
formal political voice.
They could still have some say
in defining the terms of their
subordinate place in society and
they could achieve limited ends
in doing so.
That matters a great deal.
It matters a great deal because
it prevented their complete
alienation from the existing
social order and encouraged them
to seek justice where they felt
aggrieved,
rather than simply exacting
from time to time a desperate
and bloody revenge--
and that mattered.
It could matter a great deal in
particular when the country fell
into political crisis in the
1640s.
And finally,
one last point:
the historians who write about
popular protest very often have,
towards the end of their
studies, a somewhat elegiac
tone.
That's because in the long run
the defenders of the customary
agrarian order lost.
They lost because the world
that they--that they were trying
to defend was gradually
dissolving all around them.
By the late seventeenth and
early eighteenth centuries,
the resistance of manorial
communities to agrarian change
was very largely over,
because such manorial
communities hardly existed
anymore.
Communities of tenants with a
collective interest in the
customs of the manor had
gradually given way to a rural
society consisting of landlords,
large-scale commercial farmers,
and landless agricultural
laborers who possessed very few
rights to defend.
But, if that was the case,
the tradition of protest
established in the sixteenth and
seventeenth centuries did not
entirely die.
Grain riots certainly continued.
They faded out only in the
nineteenth century when greater
agricultural productivity and
modern railway transportation
finally ironed out and
alleviated the inequalities of
supply which had once provoked
those local actions.
And as for the defense of
custom one could say,
I think, that aspects of it
were transferred into another
sphere.
Custom might be in retreat in
rural England,
but in the emerging world of
industrial England a new world
of custom was being born.
It was being born amongst the
skilled journeyman workers of
the urban trades,
amongst rural weavers,
amongst coal miners,
and seamen in the growing
merchant navy.
In all of these spheres new
customs, the customs of the
trade, were being established.
And they involved,
rather like the older agrarian
customs,
certain established
expectations and practices:
expectations regarding fair
wages,
decent working conditions,
the proper relationship which
should exist between master and
employee.
These people,
increasingly numerous in the
seventeenth century,
were the products of an
emergent capitalist market
economy.
They were its children.
They didn't oppose it as such.
But they tried to place their
own limitations on the demands
which it made upon them,
as best they could,
defending their own place
within its structures.
I'm speaking of course of the
emergence of the earliest forms
of labor organization which you
find emerging amongst the
journeymen and manufacturing
workers of the industrial
districts from the late
seventeenth century.
The context had changed,
but the essence of the
tradition could be said to have
continued in new ways for new
times.
The age of the manor was
ending, but the age of organized
labor was just beginning.